in this video we're talking some more
about the dbq or document based question
section of the ap u.s history exam
in our first video we just went through
some general strategy about how to
approach the question which asks you to
write an essay with a thesis statement
addressing this question
about the social and economic
experiences of african americans
moving from the south to the north in
the period 1910 to 1930 using a series
of primary documents which are provided
in the exam
in this video we're going to start
taking a look at these documents
and it's going to seem like this might
take forever because i'm going through
them really slowly and methodically
but actually on the exam itself you'll
be able to look at these and get a sense
of what's going on pretty quickly so
let's go through these documents one by
one and i'm going to put them up on the
screen
and go through them and take a few notes
on them so that we can see all of them
before we go about the process of
writing a thesis statement
so the first document we have here is an
african-american folk saying from the
south
in the 1910s
and the folk saying says the white man
got half the crop bull weevil took the
rest and it ain't got no home so what
does this remind you of well it's
definitely a reference here to
sharecropping
which was a system of agricultural labor
devised after the civil war
where white men would own a bunch of
land and then rent portions of it to
african american farmers
and in return those farmers had to give
portions of their crops back to the
landowners so this really ended in a
never-ending cycle of debt for
sharecroppers who could never get ahead
it also mentions the bull weevil
which was a pest that got into the
cotton crop which really reduced the
amount of cotton produced in the south
and led to a major economic crisis
and lastly it talks about a kind of
sense of dislocation right you don't
have a home because you're in serious
economic trouble
all right not bad let's move on to a
second document
all right well this one is a lot longer
so i'm going to try to squeeze it in
here
it says
it is a letter from a prospective
african-american migrant in 1917 who
lives in new orleans he writes dear sirs
being desirous of leaving the south for
the betterment of my condition
generally and seeking a home somewhere
in illinois chicago or some other
prosperous town i am at sea about the
best place to locate having a family
dependent upon me for support
i am informed by the chicago defender a
very valuable paper which has for its
purpose the uplifting of my race and of
which i am a constant reader and real
lover
that you were in a position to show some
light to one in my condition
seeking a northern home
if this is true kindly inform me by next
male the next best thing to do being a
poor man with a family to care for
i am not coming to live on flowery beds
of ease for i am a man who works
and wish to make the best i can out of
life i do not wish to come there
hoodwinked and not know where to go or
what to do
so i solicit your help in this matter
and thanking you in advance for what
advice you may be pleased to give i am
yours for success
so in this document it's a man who is
trying to relocate to the north
and he's drawing on the assistance of
the chicago defender which was a major
black newspaper
and he's also saying that he's maybe
afraid of being hoodwinked so you could
see that perhaps he's heard some rumors
that southerners moving to the north
might get into trouble or be conned
somehow
and he's also very eager to say that he
doesn't want to live on flowery beds of
ease he's a working man so he is coming
expecting to do a good job he's looking
for work and he's trying to put to rest
any stereotypes that he could be a lazy
man
okay here's our third document it is an
article
in the magazine industrial management
from 1918
and it's written by dwight thompson
farnham that's not anyone we've ever
heard of before but says he's a
efficiency expert so someone whose job
it is to make sure that businesses are
run efficiently and his article is
called negros as a source of industrial
labor here's what he says
a certain amount of segregation is
necessary at times to preserve the peace
this is especially true when negroes are
first introduced into a plant
it is a question if it is not always
best to have separate washrooms and the
like
in places where different races
necessarily come into close contact and
in places where inherited
characteristics are especially
accentuated it is better to keep their
respective folkways from clashing
wherever possible
so in this document it seems like he is
advising people who own factories to
segregate
workers so if they're going to hire
black laborers that they have to keep
them separate from whites especially in
bathrooms or places where inherited
characteristics are especially
accentuated whatever that means to me it
sounds like a sort of racist biology
that he's quoting here
i think another thing that he's saying
is he's giving a clue
that white workers in the north are not
necessarily going to be friendly to
black workers so i think it's fair to
say
that it shows that african americans
moving to the north are going to face
racism and
various forms of violence or maybe even
strikes from white people who don't want
to work with them
alright let's do one more
this is another long one
a article from a white owned newspaper
seems like that's important
from jackson mississippi
about a race riot in chicago in 1919
the article says the only surprising
feature about the race riot in chicago
yesterday is that it did not assume
larger proportions
trouble has been brewing in that city
for several months and nothing short of
exceptionally good work by the police
department can prevent further clashes
the native white population of chicago
bitterly resents the influx of negro
labor and especially the housing of
blacks in white neighborhoods the decent
hard-working law-abiding mississippi
negros who were lured to chicago by the
bait of higher wages
only to lose their jobs or forced to
accept lower pay after the labor
shortage became less acute are hereby
notified that they will be welcomed back
home and find their old positions
waiting for them mississippi may lynch a
negro when he commits the most heinous
of all crimes but we do not blow up the
innocent with bombs or explode sticks of
dynamite on their doorsteps well yauch
there's a lot going on here
first
you can see that this is a white owned
newspaper and it seems like maybe
they're trying to spread the word to
african americans who maybe have not yet
left the south that things are not that
great in the north right because they
don't want to lose their source of labor
to the north so basically they're saying
that
if african americans stay in the south
they might get lynched but that's better
than being killed in a race riot
i think
what we can take away from this
is in general there weren't many good
options for african americans in this
time period because in the south you
have lynch law and in the north you have
race riots so the question is was one
better than the other
now there are still three more documents
for us to look at and we'll get to those
in the next video but i think if we had
to kind of theorize right now about
what's going on
it seems like there are many african
americans who have been seriously hurt
economically by sharecropping and the
bull weevil infestation who are looking
to go north
but they're finding that when they go
north they may face segregation and
violence that may or may not be better
than the lynch law of the south
in the next video we'll take a look at
the last three documents and then we'll
take a stab at writing a strong thesis
statement based on this evidence